MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everybody.
My name is Akshay.
On behalf of the
Talks at Google team,
I'd like to welcome you to
this wonderful event featuring
Johnny Lever.
Johnny's been a part of the
Hindi film industry for 35
years now with over 400 films.
He's been nominated for the
Filmfare award for 13 times
and has won two of them, so
please welcome Johnny Lever.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEVER: Thank you, sir.
MALE SPEAKER: So first of
all, thank you very much
for [INAUDIBLE].
I have water for you.
So thank you very
much for coming here.
As you can see, all
these people have
joined us to listen
to you, learn
about your life a
little bit, maybe
ask you some tough questions.
So sir, let's get started here.
So you've been a comedian
most of your life.
Is comedy something
that you can learn ,
or is it something
that you're born with,
so either you're funny or not?
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
Born.
MALE SPEAKER: You
are born with it.
OK.
JOHNNY LEVER: I think so,
because I was two years old,
and my mommy used to tell me
I used to copy my grandfather.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: But sir, in
Bollywood these days, a lot
of actors are doing
comedy roles, right?
And at the same time,
there are comedians
such as yourself [INAUDIBLE].
So what is the difference
between a comedian and just
a lead actor who's doing
a comedy role as far as--
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: Everybody
wants to do comedy.
People want to laugh.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
Not only for comedian.
[APPLAUSE AND LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: So you have
done more than 400 films
in your career in
Bollywood, and you've also
done many stage performances.
Is there any star
or group of stars
that you enjoy
working with, that you
think is much easier to be funny
with some people versus others?
JOHNNY LEVER: I
enjoy with Govinda.
I enjoy working with
Govinda, because--
[CHEERS]
MALE SPEAKER: Govinda
fans in the crowd.
JOHNNY LEVER: I worked
with him in many movies.
Then Shah Rukh
Khan, Anil Kapoor.
And I work with everyone--
Salman Khan, Akshay.
I enjoy with them, but I enjoy
more with Govinda and Shah Rukh
Khan.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So at this point,
guys, if anyone
has questions in the crowd,
please raise your hand,
and there's a microphone there.
So how do you come
up with your content
when you're doing standup?
What's your inspiration?
What's your process for
coming up with new jokes
and making people laugh?
JOHNNY LEVER:
Observation, observation.
MALE SPEAKER: Observation.
JOHNNY LEVER: Every day, four,
five, six hours, we observe.
We study.
We look at people.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
Search Google.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
That I'm here, really.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, sir.
We are actually honored
to have you here.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
When we do comedy in
films, there are writers.
Writers are there.
Scripting is there.
Directors are there.
Assistants are there.
They help us.
They help, and they support.
We do good scenes,
and of course,
my contribution [INAUDIBLE].
But in stand-up,
everything is me.
Everything is mine.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
There's no writer.
Since 35 years I'm
doing stand-up.
Many items [INAUDIBLE] written.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER:
Audience, question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
welcome, Johnny Bhai.
Welcome to Google.
Thanks for coming here.
I grew up watching your
[HINDI] and celebrities
[SPEAKING HINDI].
So one question, because
Would you be kind enough
to share an incident, which
was like a little serous
and tragic kind of a thing,
and you went there
and [SPEAKING HINDI]?
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[CRYING NOISES]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Sir, I have a
short follow-up question.
Sir, here.
JOHNNY LEVER: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Short follow-up question.
Sir, these days,
actually, YouTube
has created a platform by
itself of all the consumers.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
Why don't you join
something like TVF,
which is hugely
popular in India,
and we would like to love to
see you on that TVF series?
JOHNNY LEVER: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Are you already--
are you planning to join TVF?
"The Total Viral
Fever," they produce
all these humorous content
and showcase it on YouTube.
So I was hoping you could
become part of that,
and like, you know, you can
globally reach everywhere.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Why do you think
that is the case?
Or in your experience
[SPEAKING HINDI],
does it get easier?
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI],
Robin Williams
and Charlie Chaplin--
these people
suffered a lot in their lives.
They were very depressed.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So you
brought up your wife.
I'm [SPEAKING HINDI].
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I'm helpless here.
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
This is also something
I'm learning.
Audience question.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Day-to-day personal life.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
Does it help you to deal with
[HINDI] stressful situation?
Do you like think of it
in a comedic setting?
Does it help you in that sense?
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Stand-up and then movies.
[HINDI] which is
your favorite style?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you.
AUDIENCE: Sir, [HINDI] your
onscreen chemistry comedy
[HINDI], that we really enjoyed.
But my question is that behind
screen, [SPEAKING HINDI].
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Is that something on your mind?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
A for apple, B for blackberry,
C for CPU, D for download,
E for email, F for Facebook,
G for Google, H for Hotmail,
I for internet, J for joystick,
K for keyboard, L for laptop,
M for monitor, N for netbook,
O for OLX, P for printer,
Q for [INAUDIBLE], R for
[INAUDIBLE], S for software,
T for Twitter, U for
upload, V for virus,
W for [INAUDIBLE], X for Xerox,
Y for YouTube, Z for zip file.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hello, sir.
Thank you for coming here.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
We are professional
[SPEAKING HINDI].
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Is there anything happening
in Bollywood to change this?
[SPEAKING HINDI]?
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Is this a concern?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
AUDIENCE: So on that
note, [SPEAKING HINDI].
I'd like to invite her up here.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: Hi.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
OK, Jamie, welcome.
JAMIE LEVER: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you for joining us.
So Jamie, I am actually
very interested in knowing
[SPEAKING HINDI].
And more importantly,
[SPEAKING HINDI], or
did he let you fall
and learn on your own?
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI].
I was in London at that point.
I was studying.
I was doing my post-graduation.
And [SPEAKING HINDI].
I was doing a couple of other
things also [SPEAKING HINDI] is
to watch a lot of things and is
to also do my little bit plays
[HINDI] on the side.
And while I was there, my
comedy show [SPEAKING HINDI].
And I just felt like,
you know, [HINDI].
I should be on that
stage, and I should
have that mic in
my hand, and I know
that I can do a better job.
Oops.
I know I can do a
better job of that.
So [SPEAKING HINDI].
And then I just at that
time, [HINDI] father,
he just happened
to be in London.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I want to do comedy.
And then he's like
[SPEAKING HINDI].
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI].
I just wrote them
down. [SPEAKING HINDI].
Hello, how are you doing?
OK.
Sorry.
No, thank you.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I'm just saying all this,
and then [SPEAKING HINDI].
And people just stood up,
and they started applauding.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
And then I started doing comedy.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HINDI].
You're seeing her grow in the
industry and [SPEAKING HINDI].
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI].
And I thought [HINDI], my father
would tell me [SPEAKING HINDI].
Figure it out.
[SPEAKING HINDI] newly
opened [SPEAKING HINDI].
And I just called them,
and I said, you know what?
I'm a new comedian and
struggling and trying
to figure out, so can
I perform? [HINDI],
OK, we'll give you a slot.
[SPEAKING HINDI],
and they really
liked me [SPEAKING HINDI].
And then after that,
[SPEAKING HINDI].
I just went and secretly
gave my audition.
They really liked me.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
You're booked for
the entire season.
These are your dates.
You're not doing anything else.
We need you on the show.
And in fact, [SPEAKING HINDI].
Nobody knew that I am
Johnny Lever's daughter.
And [SPEAKING HINDI].
And we were all like all the
new comedians are working hard
[SPEAKING HINDI].
And all the senior
comedians [SPEAKING HINDI].
Krishna and all
these people came.
And they had no idea
[SPEAKING HINDI].
But they just came
And they were
interviewing me and all.
[SPEAKING HINDI], and
we were in a boardroom,
and we were sitting.
And we were talking.
They just asked me
casually, [SPEAKING HINDI]?
They were really happy.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: Workshop.
JAMIE LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
She returned my fees.
MALE SPEAKER: So Jamie, your
dad has an amazing legacy.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
How much pressure
does that put on you?
JAMIE LEVER: It's a huge
responsibility, because [HINDI]
expect, and there's so
much competition today,
so people expect a lot.
But the good thing is that he's
been in this field for so long,
and he's made so
many people laugh,
and people love him so much
that they've accepted me also
with the same love.
And every time I come onstage,
they give me-- they smile,
and they applaud, so it
feels really special.
I feel welcomed.
I feel really happy
to be in this place.
But I know [SPEAKING HINDI],
I have to work really hard,
and there's a lot
of competition,
so I'm working on that.
I'm just-- I keep preparing.
I keep studying.
I keep learning.
So that'll continue always.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE LEVER: [SINGING IN HINDI]
MALE SPEAKER: Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
JAMIE LEVER: One English
song for you guys.
[SINGING] And I, I
will always love you.
I will always love you,
oh, and I will always
love you, love, love, love you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That was amazing.
JAMIE LEVER: Thank you.
I try to just incorporate
singing in my acts.
I do comedy.
I sing also, but really comedy.
MALE SPEAKER: So you're here
with your father for a show.
Tell us a little bit
about when you're here
and what the show is about.
JAMIE LEVER: OK.
So our show is on the 18th, as
you can see. [SPEAKING HINDI].
It's an out and out comedy show,
a Hindi stand up comedy show.
You can come with
your entire family,
and it's like watching
a Bollywood film.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
And it's just going to be-- it's
a hilarious, fun comedy show,
which you will definitely love.
My father performs
with two [INAUDIBLE],
or [SPEAKING HINDI]
act, 20 minutes [HINDI].
And yeah, it's just a
full on comedy show.
I think Daddy can
explain better.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI]
Dance, music, humor,
[SPEAKING HINDI].
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
So I think we're
out of time, guys.
Let's thank Mr. Johnny Lever
and Jamie Lever for visiting us.
JOHNNY LEVER: [SPEAKING HINDI].
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.